das macht man nicht das kann man doch
nicht machen erzählt x hey leute was
glaubt man jetzt bekommen bei neue video
heute geht es mal um so eine sache die
mich in letzter zeit zu immer zu nehmen
beziehungsweise hier jetzt kann ich halt
so drüber reden weil es eh jeder weiß
oder halt auch aus einer anderen
situation
es geht zum umso vorfälle wo ich mir
dachte so leute so also leute die meine
videos druck abonnenten von mir oder
keine ahnung wer dem ich kann
wahrscheinlich von youtube oder
instagram kaplan halt so vorfälle wo ich
mir wirklich gedacht habe schild doch
jetzt mal alter wieso macht ihr das man
dass das kann man doch gar nicht bringen
so ich persönlich ich könnte mich gar
nicht in diese rolle hinein versetzen
das bei anderen personen zu machen ich
würde mich irgendwie falsch ebenso und
ja meine haare sind heftig lang geworden
ich muss wieder zum friseur liga achte
ich auf meine haare heute also leute
eine situation die sie gestern passiert
ich bin gestern nach köln gefahren wird
aus einem zug ausgestiegen
es war so keine ahnung halb zwölf oder
so und ich musste noch so eineinhalb
kilometer gehen um halt zu einem kumpel
so komme ich hab gedacht ihr kommen
gehst du das stück einfach war ein
schönes wetter noch die sonne hat
geschienen bildern durch die innenstadt
so ganz kurz und direkt wirklich direkt
ich dachte jungs habt ihr keine schule
also das war ein junge und mädchen ich
merke mittlerweile wirklich immer ob
mich jemand jetzt erkennt oder nicht und
die haben mich halt erkannt habe ich so
im hinter die haben also ist dass ich in
youtube so habe ich gehört und weiter
ging dachte ich okay die gehen jetzt
weiter ich gehe weiter war nicht so die
sind mir hinterher gegangen wirklich ein
kilometer oder so sind ihm hinterher
gelaufen so da hab ich noch gedacht so
ok ja die waren auch noch etwas jünger
so ich weiß nicht warum ich in der
schule waren oder woher die kamen keine
ahnung bayern oder so hat ja auch ferien
und das ding ist dabei wirklich immer
ich frag mich so merkt ihr nicht dass
ich komplett checke dass ihm hinterher
läuft oder dass das hier mich kennt oder
sonst woher kennen weiß ich nicht so
weil der junge von denen der kann auch
wirklich immer so auf meine höhe ich
habe in der kapuze auf und guckte danach
so liegt er wieder zurück ist das blabla
und irgendwann habe ich mich dann
umgedreht und gesagt was wollt ihr
kommen ich kann bei sowas autos war so
nett bleiben wie ich eigentlich bin
bisher so diese gleiche situation
ähnliche situation ist mir noch mal
passiert hier bei uns oder auch schon
des öfteren ich war letztens mit meiner
freundin war ich bei uns in der
innenstadt halt hier wo ich wohne liest
nicht sonderlich groß aber ist halt man
kann ist relativ schön so und hier im
ort wissen natürlich schon so relativ
viele bescheid dass sich youtube mache
weil ich halt ihr wohnen und das spricht
sich dann natürlich um ist ja logisch so
auf jeden fall bin ich damit meine
freunde so ein weg gelaufen und da waren
halt so fünf mädchen und artenreich
mercure ibis noch dass ich jude mache
und zwei oder drei von ich glaube es
waren zwei von diesen mädchen
sie nutzt dann hinterher gelaufen wo ich
dachte okay gut sprechen mich jetzt
sofort an ihm traut sich vielleicht auch
nicht so immer das war allerdings nicht
so wir haben es dann hingesetzt und auch
wieder so total offensichtlich sind
wieso die waren es 100 meter entfernt
dann 50 meter dann 20 meter dann sind
die an uns vorbei gelaufen
traust du dich verbleib haben sich dann
fünf meter neben uns hingesetzt und uns
ohne scheiß um drei viertel lang
angeguckt und beobachtet so wo ich mir
dein geld leute dass das macht man doch
nicht das kann man doch nicht machen
erzählt mag ich weiß ich wie man dazu
fähig sein kann ok die war jetzt
vielleicht auch nicht 16 oder 17
aber auch mit 14 sollte man das schon
lernen soll oder wissen wo die grenzen
liegen das sind dann wirklich so
situation da denke ich merkt ihr das
nicht dass ich euch schon vor einer
stunde bemerkt hat oder so und jetzt
auch noch mal so eine situation die ich
nicht verstanden hab so klar vielleicht
was auch ein bisschen dumm von mir ich
hab halt mal meine freundin bei
instagram unter so einem foto markiert
das heißt darauf hingewiesen hat sodass
man halt schon eine freundin hat und das
haben dann irgendwie anders gesehen die
mir auf instagram voll beziehungsweise
die halt in diesem moment das sehen
konnten und dann ging es natürlich los
und haben ein neues ein foto der hatten
freunde dass seine freundin bla bla bla
bla bla bla ob die kommentare schnell
gelöscht aber auf den kommentar unter
dem foto greif konnte keiner mehr sehen
und ein mädchen das war wirklich dabei
da dachte ich okay die ist 12 also
wirklich so einem mädchen das ist
vielleicht noch nicht gelernt hat somit
zwölf würde ich mir denken gut du hast
vielleicht auch nicht gelernt das kommt
mit der zeit so hätte ich verständnis
für das war allerdings ein weg sein
mädchen wo ich halt auf das profil gang
in die war sitzt endlich ganz normales
mädchen 17 jahre alt und ich schrieb
dann immer wieder hh ist sie das
peinlich dass du eine freundin hat
kommentar gelöscht
mein gott ihm ist es peinlich kommentar
gelöscht und irgendwann habe ich dir
einfach blockiert weil ich dachte was
ist falsch
ich habe das nicht geschenkt so mit 17
jahren das muss man doch verstehen dass
man das
vielleicht nicht so wollt und irgendwann
checken und einfach leise sein aber nein
das sind halt wirklich immer so sachen
in letzter zeit die kann ich nicht
verstehen und ich finds halt schade das
ist so ist weil man muss das doch
irgendwann muss das doch verstehen wo
die grenzen sind und wo nicht dazu was
mit dem video wollte ich nur mal kurz
sagen für zwischendurch
am sonntag kommt ein 300.000 abos peschl
um 42 online-check dass auf jeden fall
ab aber nicht vergessen nicht zuwarten
ihr könnt gerne auch nach oben hier da
lassen wenn es euch gefallen hat
bisschen unterhalten
jung links geht es weiter mit einem
video-chat das ab sonntag kommt wie
gesagt dass man kommt auf dem video an
einem morgen kommt neuer bringt er es
schließlich geworden
dies sei